le futsal était à l'honneur à fontenay
le fleury la ville a accueilli ce
dimanche 30 avril au gymnase descartes
les finales de la coupe les yvelines au
programme sept matches de la catégorie
des moins de 12 ans aux seniors
comme souvent dans le futsal les
rencontres ont été ultra spectaculaire
avec notamment un 17-1 entre le psg le
fc mantois dans la catégorie u16
féminine on peut perdre 3 0 et à
l'arrivée gagné 5-3 c'est plutôt une
attaque défense quoi
c'est à dire que les joueurs arrière on
pour envoyer les ballons devant et c'est
que les attaquants puisque les avoir
pour marquer dans la catégorie senior
féminine les joueuses de l'ice
montigny-le-bretonneux habitué à jouer à
onze sur un grand terrain se sont lancés
dans l'aventuré futsal cette saison
après avoir réussi à se hisser en finale
lésiné monteyne qui jouent en blanc se
sont finalement inclinés contre
croissy-sur-seine sur le score de 4 buts
à 1 je pense qu'on entre guillemets on
fait des cadeaux en première mi-temps et
puis on joue pas le haut doubs pas le
match à fond fait quelques erreurs
tactiques par rapport à ce qu'avait dit
le coach au début du match
et bah c'est ce qui nous coûte les deux
premiers buts après c'est compliqué à
une fois qu'on se prend un but dès le
début de la deuxième mi temps après pour
revenir c'est vrai que elle va elle
sermonne jeu et c'est compliqué de
marquer on a pas mal d'occasions on
cadre pas aussi toutes les occases qu'on
a donc montigny le bretonneux tentera de
monter une nouvelle équipe l'année
prochaine pour remporter la coupe en
attendant les joueuses vont tenter
d'arracher noté en dh en fin de saison
mais cette fois ci sur la pollution